et
lorsque je me souviens de mon enfance il
ya une quarantaine d'années en arrière
et que je pense aux jeux auxquels je
m'adonnais avec mes amis je revois des
cordes à sauter je revois des marraines
et aujourd'hui que je suis maire quand
j'observe les enfants qui jouent ces
jeux ne sont plus d'actualité
ce que je trouve aujourd'hui ce sont des
enfants qui jouent en face d'eux
d'ordinateurs qui joue avec des consoles
de jeux vidéo qui s'amusent avec des
téléphones sur lesquels ils ont
téléchargé des applications qui
échangent avec leurs amis un total
changement
qu'est-ce qui a sous-tendu ce changement
certes 40 années sont passées mais ce
sont surtout les progrès de la
technologie c'est l'innovation qui a été
mise à la portée de tous et ce n'est
plus de la technologie qui restent dans
les laboratoires c'est de la technologie
qui viennent dans notre vie de tous les
jours
regardez autour de vous au quotidien
pensez un peu à l'évolution qu'on a vécu
depuis c'est au cours de ces dernières
années
souvenez vous quand il fallait
transférer de l'argent il fallait la
poste pour rédiger ses mandats poste ça
depuis longtemps été remplacée par
simplement du transfert électronique
d'argent
pensez à la démarche qu'il fallait faire
d'aller dans son agence bancaire pour
remplir un formulaire et retirer de
l'argent
aujourd'hui vous suffit de sortir et de
rechercher le 1er distributeur au coin
de la rue et vous retirer votre argent
toutes ces exemples sont des exemples où
la technologie a révolutionné mais ce
n'est pas simplement l'aspect pratique
penser à la médecine aujourd'hui avec
toutes les révolutions de la technologie
on arrive à concevoir des appareils de
diagnostic qui sont révolutionnaires qui
permettent de déceler des maladies très
tôt et de pouvoir les traiter avec des
médicaments qui eux
si on bénéficiait de l'innovation avec
des stress des spectres beaucoup plus
étroit et qui arrive à trouver des
traitements plus efficaces pour soigner
tous des maladies qui par le passé
étaient vraiment des cas difficiles
l'industrialisation en ait encore
bénéficier donc tout ceci pour vous dire
que la technologie aujourd'hui au cours
de ces derniers d'années de ce dernier
siècle a totalement révolutionné notre
environnement et on n'est plus dans un
environnement de conception de théorie
c'est de la pratique
la technologie nous entoure on a eu
quelques soucis ce matin en commençant
cette émission la technologie nous
entoure et lorsque je pense à cela et
que je regarde comment nos économies
évolué je vois que en côte d'ivoire en
afrique même dans tous les pays du monde
l'essor de l'économie va vraiment se
baser sur l'appropriation de cette
innovation
l'appropriation de la technologie qui va
permettre à nos économies de faire un
bon mais je constate qu'il ya beaucoup
de femmes qui sont absentes de ce
périmètre
après tout représentant pratiquement 50%
de la population
malheureusement malheureusement dans le
domaine de la technologie nous ne sommes
pas bien représentés pourquoi à quoi bon
sony est ce que quelqu'un de vous peut
me donner par exemple
à son avis le pourcentage de
scolarisation de filles par rapport aux
garçons côte d'ivoire juste comme ça
40%
la dernière étude du pew sur l'égalité
des sexes en côte d'ivoire montre que
nous sommes pratiquement à parité et le
gouvernement également a mis en place
une obligation depuis septembre 2015 que
tout les enfants entre 6 et 16 ans
soient scolarisés ce qui permet
aujourd'hui en côte d'ivoire d'avoir à
l'école primaire des enfants dans des
classes avec 87 filles pour 100 garçons
87% de scolarisation des filles dans les
effectifs
par rapport aux garçons ça montre qu'on
ferme dont formidable on est presque à
la parité
vous allez me dire c'est positif c'est
même très bien
mais au cours de ses études lorsqu'on
arrive à la fin du cursus
qu'est ce qu'on constate au moment de
faire des orientations d'université
qu'est ce qu'on constate que les filles
ont du mal à s'orienter vers des
disciplines scientifiques et
technologiques
et ce n'est pas uniquement le cas de la
côte d'ivoire c'est mondiale je voulais
prendre l'exemple de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche scientifique
aujourd'hui parmi tous les chercheurs du
monde
nous avons uniquement un tiers de femmes
en afrique on salit 34%
mais ces 34% sont totalement inégaux sur
le continent on a une formidable
disparités vous voyez ici que au
cap-vert 52% et femmes sont chercheurs
alors qu'en guinée parmi les chercheurs
il n'y a que 6 % de femmes
pourquoi comment expliquer cela
cette absence de femmes dans les
technologies et dans les sciences
est ce que c'est parce que les jeunes
filles ont peur manque de confiance en
elle
est ce que c'est parce que les jeunes
filles ont peur de prendre des risques
qu'elles préfèrent aller dans des
disciplines qui sont réputées plus
facile ou plus simple ou alors elles ne
savent pas vraiment quel sont les
carrières qui s'offrent à elles
lorsqu'elles auront fait des études
d'ingénieur ou des études scientifiques
dans les laboratoires faisons-nous la
question pour moi par exemple qui n'est
que des sorts j'ai grandi dans une
famille où il n'y a que des filles je
n'ai pas perçu cette ségrégation qu'il y
aurait peut-être dans les familles en
égard son aîné fille peut-être qu'il y
en a certains qui l'ont expérimenté mais
est-ce que déjà au sein de la cellule
familiale
on ne donnerait pas réfléchi
ir à l'éducation qu'on donne à nos
filles pourquoi est ce que il faudrait
toujours que la fille soit en rose et
que le garçon soit en bleu pourquoi est
ce qu'il faudrait que chaque fois qu'il
ya des cadeaux la fille soit avec la
poupée et la dignité que le garçon avec
les voitures et le jeu de construction
alors que si vous mettez un jeu les
enfants ne regarde pas de quel jeu il
s'agit il y joue au sein de la cellule
familiale déjà il faut qu'on pense à
permettre à la petite fille de se dire
qu'elle a autant un cerveau que son
frère et qu'elle ne doit pas simplement
rester cantonné à des tâches ménagères
ou alors à des disciplines qui sont
réputés être des disciplines de filles
et voilà le rôle des parents aussi qui
devient de plus en plus important
toujours pour parler de mon parcours
j'ai effet à 1 10 et 1 cuil un collège
et un lycée de jeunes filles encore
j'étais dans un vase un peu clos où nous
n'étions que des filles pendant notre
scolarité
je vois avec beaucoup de bonheur
quelques anciennes de mon lycée mais à
cette époque là à nouveau on n'avait pas
la perception de cette différence parce
qu'on ne l'ait on n'en faisait pas
l'expérience au moment de faire un choix
j'ai dit à mes parents que je souhaitais
faire une carrière d'ingénieur
personne n'a froncer les sourcils
personne ne m'a dit oh ma fille qu'est
ce que tu dis là on m'a dit si tu veux
le faire tu le fais mais tu le fais bien
et c'est ça que je pense qu'il faut
qu'on dise à nos filles aujourd'hui fait
des choix
mais tenez vous à vos choix j'avoue
quand même que lorsque j'étais dans ma
série scientifique dans mon lycée nous
n'étions pas nombreux arts en terminale
c et on a même dû ramener d'autres
élèves pour pouvoir faire un effectif
complet et c'est là lorsque j'ai décidé
donc de faire une carrière d'ingénieur
en commençant par des classes
préparatoires que je suis tombé dans la
vraie vie
là on arrive en classe prépa et on se
retrouve être la seule fille dans une
classe de 20 où elles sont les autres
nulle part et on était une promotion de
élève avec quatre filles en saisie
qu'est ce qu'une jeune élève qui vient
d'avoir son bac et qui rentre dans une
carrière et qui souhaitent faire des
études avec une carrière d'ingénieur
pourrait se dire oh là là j'ai fait le
mauvais choix
peut-être que je devrai reconsidérer mon
orientation
mais non nous étions quatre heureusement
parmi ces 80 et nous nous sommes dit
faisons de notre singularité notre force
travail en travaillant dur pour leur
montrer que même si on est une fille on
arrive à exceller dans les disciplines
scientifiques et technologiques
vous n'allez pas être à l'abri des
préjugés et des stéréotypes qui vont
dire oh
annick faut s'accrocher parce que les
filles ça va pas dans l'espace donc en
dessin industriel on sait pas ce que ça
va donner pour toi ou alors oh là là et
mathématiques tu sais les filles n'ont
pas la bosse des mathématiques
mais ce sont des préjugés qu'il faut
amener progressivement à faire
disparaître et encourager les jeunes
filles dansaient dans ces disciplines
parce que j'ai été vraiment très très
assidus dans ses cours et on se rend
compte que ces préjugés viennent
peut-être du fait que les autres ne vous
connaissent pas en échangeant avec en
travaillant avec eux ils seront
condamnés tient là comme un cerveau elle
peut nous aider dans telle ou telle
matière elle est une étudiante comme
nous abattre les barrières motiver les
jeunes filles a continué et cette
expérience cette confrontation avec la
réalité du monde s'est poursuivie
lorsque j'ai eu mon premier emploi dans
un laboratoire de recherche et
développement une équipe de 30
ingénieurs en europe seule femme seule
africaine la curiosité vraiment du
laboratoire mais qu'est ce qui t'a amené
à être
dans cette discipline mais c'était une
expérience passionnante cette année dans
ces périodes de recherche et
développement parce que lorsqu'on aime
quelque chose lorsqu'on a la volonté de
le faire
on partage avec les autres cette passion
est tout de suite c'est face les limites
qui peuvent être des préjugés
effectivement ou des idées reçues qui
disent que les femmes sont compétentes
que les hommes
donc mon propos aujourd'hui par rapport
à ce thème de l'avant garde
malheureusement nous sommes encore loin
d'être au niveau où nous souhaiterions
avec les jeunes filles qui soit dans ces
matières est dans cette discipline
mais en réfléchissant bien nos économies
ont besoin de ressources qualifiées sans
considération du genre on a besoin de
personnel qualifié de ressources qui
vont permettre d'intégrer l'innovation
et le développement dans notre nos
économies que ce soit dans les
infrastructures que ce soit dans la
construction que ce soit dans la santé
toutes ces disciplines ont besoin de
ressources
je disais nous sommes 50 % de la
population pourquoi est ce que pour ces
métiers pointus il y aurait pas autant
de femmes que d'hommes
et cette responsabilité nous incombe à
tous
c'est vrai je disais que j'étais seul
mais j'aimerais bien que cela change il
y avait trois start part mais j'ai vu
quand même dans le film qui avait des
jeunes filles qui avait des projets nous
devons accompagner nos jeunes filles
nous devons leur donner cette confiance
en elle et là où dire que si elles ont
les capacités
si elles sont volontaires en travaillant
elles peuvent délivrer des résultats au
même titre que leurs collègues masculins
et elles peuvent embrasser ses carrières
scientifiques et être deux d'excellents
ingénieurs d'excellents chercheurs
pourquoi est-ce que lorsqu'il s'agit de
prendre des décisions par rapport à
l'orientation
les pères dirais à leur fils oui mon
fils va dans une carrière scientifique
dans une filière scientifique parce que
comme ça tu seras pilotes
d'avions que tu seras chercheurs tu
seras ingénieure c'est mon aujourd'hui
ces métiers se conjugue au féminin et je
suis sûr que au fond de vous celles qui
avaient des appréhensions pour embrasser
ses carrières doivent être en train de
se poser la question est ce que je fais
le bon choix oui vous faites le bon
choix parce que la technologie fait
partie du quotidien
aujourd'hui nos sociétés ne pourront pas
évoluer son technologies et les femmes
ne peuvent pas rester en marge de cette
révolution là il faut que nous prenions
notre part également est que nous
arrivions à contribuer au développement
de nos pays et pour cela comme je disais
la responsabilité nous en sommes tous en
tant que parent déjà comme je le disais
pour aider nos enfants à avoir confiance
en eux et surtout les filles
rien est impossible à qui veut il faut y
aller il faut avoir le courage et il
faut avoir surtout la volonté
ne brisons pas les rêves des jeunes
filles en leur disant les sciences et
pas pour toi ingénieurs non tu ne feras
pas ça c'est un métier d'homme aucun
métier est un métier d'homme vous aussi
les hommes d'ailleurs je vous interpelle
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes tous un
père un frère un collègue vous aussi
encourager toutes ces jeunes filles qui
ont des vocations qui ont peut-être
quelques doutes mais rassure aînés
dites-leur qu'elles ont sont capables
dites leur que vous n'avez aucun
problème à compétir avec l assister les
mêmes sur le monde professionnel des
employeurs également doivent donner des
opportunités aux femmes il y a plein de
nouveaux métiers qui se développe parce
que justement ces nouvelles technologies
apportent de nouvelles opportunités et
donc génère des nouveaux métiers
on parle de webdesigner on parle de
designers industriels pour travailler
sur de nouveaux robots qui vont aider la
science qui vont s'allier aux
communications pour aider dans la
microchirurgie ou dans la télé chez
logis on parle de datation disent qu'ils
vont vraiment aller avec tous ses
volumes de données aujourd'hui chercher
l'essence même de l'information pour
pouvoir déceler des tendances qui
pourront être utilisés pour la météo
prévision de catastrophe naturelle
anticipation applications dans le monde
de l'agriculture imaginez si un planteur
ce qui peut avoir des informations
fiables sur la météo et savoir à quel
moment planté à quel moment arrosée on a
des problèmes avec les ressources en eau
tout ça ce sont des opportunités pour
les jeunes filles elles ne devraient pas
s'en passer et nous autres les femmes
qui sommes dans ces domaines là nous
devons tendre la main aux jeunes soeurs
leur dire que nous pouvons les
accompagner parce qu'il ya déjà des
femmes qui sont dans ce secteur-là
parler dans les écoles leur donner
l'information sur les carrières
possibles leur donner la confiance en
elle pour qu'elle sache que elles
peuvent y aller faire du mentorat les
jeunes professionnels les accompagner
leur donner confiance en elle et surtout
les préparer à accéder à des rôles de
manager et à des positions de manager si
elles ont un rêve il faut que l s'y
accroche
et comme disait tout à l'heure bintou si
vous avez un rêve et que vous voulez
décrocher la lune ce n'est pas un
handicap au contraire il faut y aller je
vais finir par cette citation d'une
ingénieure américaine et jay nixon qui
avait justement ce euros ce rêve d'aller
dans l'espace et dans l'année dans la
lune et est là avec détermination réussi
à le réaliser et je vais lui emprunter
sa citation
ne laissez personne vous priver de vos
rêves vous priver de votre imagination
vous priver de votre création et dans
votre curiosité parce que c'est votre
place dans le monde et nous sommes 50 %
c'est votre vie il faut persévérer
il faut aller de l'avant il faut faire
de votre vie celle que vous voulez
qu'elle soit mais
merci madame sakho
[Applaudissements]